[Music]
so this dude over here xlp put together
something i thought was you would enjoy
we would all enjoy uh kalila
uh the title of this is the most
sadistic woman in comedy
because i was [ __ ] my brother at a
hospital was it was that the first time
you [ __ ] your brother
no but it was maybe like
maybe like the third time but i mean he
was a very like sweet meek boy he he's
he's past you know he
killed him
himself probably because he slept with
his sister
and he couldn't live with the guilt and
unlike you who are just plowing through
it on your on your wes anderson podcast
set and you're and you're talking about
how he was like this meek shy guy which
means you pushed this thing to happen
too
you're right if he was like this meme
you're probably the pushy one and [ __ ]
him and then he killed himself and this
woman
if this woman is like one of those
like
succubus like evil things like where
everything she goes there's just death
and destruction and like well like if
kala [ __ ] frozen for example we would
know she came onto him and [ __ ] him
frozen was not the aggressor in that
situation
no offense frozen but she'd kill you
yeah i know not too long after no
offense frozen but you'd allow it
oh definitely see
well frozen here's your going away
present
if you look behind you she'll be walking
through your door look we just found a
filipino girl that kind of looked like
her it's the best we could afford on
short notice okay it might be a dude it
might be that we don't know okay i used
to jerk off dogs a lot
okay this one i hadn't heard this is a
new one for me um
i don't want her anymore um
what what
okay energy she's available oh um hey
kalila
elaborate
computer elaborate
killed himself at not too long after
i used to jerk off dogs a lot
but this isn't like a known thing
close-up of
ah [ __ ] theo i look i don't care
anymore i gotta get the [ __ ] out of l.a
i will always love theo vaughn you know
what man [ __ ] louisiana ain't all
that bad
i think i'm gonna head back to the
[ __ ] by you i can't take this [ __ ] no
more every time i see theo it feels like
a fish out of water movie [ __ ]
is gonna this [ __ ] needs to just
go home yeah and live the rest of his
life eating gumbo and [ __ ] gambling and
shreveport get away from these people by
the way they'll give you a casino a
residency at a shreveport casino
easy peasy take it yeah you want the top
floor of the you know the gold the
golden lucky coin casino
i'm sorry it would be the shreveport
mirage there you go
so i'm father few she's not even white
no she's filipino and she's [ __ ] dogs
and which is weird because you guys
normally eat them yeah we eat them not
okay one thing
if other people want to go find them and
this is the guy that things that are in
the open already that's on them the
original
you steered the right okay this is what
i wanted let's get back
somebody found a blog he found the blog
with some of her poems do you want to
see some of her poems back to the
original are they good
i ran you ragged to the gravel fed you
time for gold held you closely so
falsely watched your ache unfold
you steered the reins as you were aptly
told not knowing you were headed for a
stab capture and hold you know is this
about [ __ ] her dog or [ __ ] her
brother or [ __ ] her brother's dog
ruin ruining bobby lee's brain i don't
know what this is she's done so many
horrible things man women
there's nothing worse than women that
because all women try poetry at some
point yeah it's so bad
like sweat on a hot summer sidewalk
i'm sorry so sorry for your heart i
cajoled and for thieving back all the
things i sold
i'm an artist a con self-punished but
parole i hate her a savvy salvatore
spoiling good to mold i hate her for
this i ask pardon your good faith i have
trolled i know nothing of love but a
dead
winter's
cold she's so bad boo
boo
boo boo this woman cynthia
cynthia uh you are dead
you are b-pop
the standout lines here obviously fed
you time for gold
held you closely so falsely and i'm an
artist a con all of which amount to what
i can only interpret as a blatant
admission of gold digging
yeah no i mean i can't argue that you're
actually you're 100 right yeah when you
say that it hurts my feelings why
because what if we were poor
it would be more difficult
if we were
you know i remember all of which
amounted to this is like a year or two
after this moment by the way again i
want to plug this xlp i'll have the link
in the description
this clip
was one of the clips
that really started this was like a year
and a half two years ago this was the
beginning of everybody on reddit being
like
yeah i hate this [ __ ] okay
yeah this is one i must have missed i i
didn't i was more into the brendan
callan stuff i really didn't read too
much and didn't know too much about the
bobby thing you throw money at my tears
which is okay
you know what
okay when you say that it hurts my
feelings why because what if we were
poor
it would be more difficult
if we were poor papa you we would be
divorced because there's no way you know
how to show me love
papa
bro
he'd never seen no no no no i swear to
god
i knew the brother thing this was i
didn't know the dog [ __ ] thing and i
didn't know this i did know a couple
years ago that bobby lee's blowing his
cousin thing i remember that no this was
i remember this being because people
always kind of disliked her
but then when she did this one time this
was like the reddit started being like
this piece of [ __ ]
okay when you say that it hurts my
feelings why because what if we were
poor
it would be more difficult
if we were poor papa you we would be
divorced because there's no way you know
how to show me love
i like that
i love that this guy does these
close-ups of the people's reactions as a
matter of fact let me sub to him now
because this guy only has like three
subscribers
um
i'm gonna post it and i posted in the
chat what a [ __ ] evil thing to say to
somebody it's it's gross right
there you go
subscribe to that guy
um
here
what
because
[Laughter]
and if we were poor what would you throw
up my tears
i have two ideas
you have two eyes i have two hands here
we are see works works out perfectly
love
love
that's funny
okay anyways
this isn't like because we we obviously
we bust each other's balls a lot but if
anyone's looking at us they would go oh
their friends are busting each other's
balls that is not the face of somebody
who is busting somebody's balls no that
is the face of like yeah and she the way
she's like
just just kind of the way she treats him
and then
this has been like ongoing for a long
time but this was sort of when the
cracks started showing yeah
how do you just admit that to somebody
i love you
and you notice she's do you notice how
this was before trash tuesdays this is
when kalila was just around and was
bobby's you know [ __ ] hole
and uh
you notice how much
her like posture and the way she talks
is she like she's basically used bobby
built up her own little thing
and now
you notice like she's way more like
aggressive and assertive now and
outspoken and she used to not be like
that she used to have the little baby
baby boy yeah and now
she's sort of just
like i don't need bobby anymore and now
she's like trying to make herself into a
thing she's terrible
kalala would address it by offering two
thousand dollars to whoever doxes the
innocent redditor as a matter of fact
i'll give you any tiger before this i
remember holly listener two thousand
dollars of my own money if you find the
ip address of this person
it's kind of illegal
not his money
his money
her money after initially laughing at
the idea bobby would say that this
sounded insane asking what she would do
if she found the information just from
your face just your face i know
it's getting [ __ ] crazy it's getting
ridiculous
and it is
the ghost i thought it was i said it was
interesting no both of them work no it's
not interesting what are you gonna do
wrath
once kalila sees this negative response
she says she would just invite them on
the podcast
no no what happens if you find the name
i want that person to be on our podcast
i'm sure they're going to feel
comfortable going to the podcast after
you dox them found their ip address and
then by the way finding somebody's ipad
doesn't necessarily mean you know where
they live
um no
you want ah okay
bobby responds with oh so you want blank
hinting at some enemy in the podcasting
world that they would want on
bobby says there's only a list of about
five people who would want to do
something like this
but it's it's one of five names to do
what i'm saying to remember because i
don't know i guess i'm so sorry you know
what i got it i can tell you write it
real quick
his money yeah your money her let's have
it listed as one of the most notable
things about her
after the reddit post would gain
traction kalila would address it by
offering two thousand dollars
oh it was a reddit postcard so read a
post about uh with many famous youtubers
she hosts tiger belly one husband she
also invites very famous journalists
everybody's a podcast show because
animal lovers she likes you michelle so
to your avenger being a dog lover shifty
okay so okay so all right all right i
got it i got it it makes sense i got i
got it dick [ __ ] dude
i think it was probably just a [ __ ]
cheeto fingered little dick [ __ ] dude
there we go there's zayn hey kalila
we'll come on your show
a little cheeto dick you want us i could
i mean i don't want to go to la but i
could i could write it off yeah
there's the anger but i mean i
when in think
history of anything other than like vice
have have is has there ever been a true
interview of a cheeto finger troll
yeah what's the cheeto finger oh because
she's witty and she's basically cheeto
finger is her take it's like a fun take
on guy who lives with his mom or get out
of your mom's basement gotcha cheeto
fingert is implying that all they do is
they sit down and they eat cheetos yeah
yeah yeah yeah remember cheetos what's
wrong with cheetos it was i don't know
cheeto dude versus you who's a cheetah
so i mean whatever
right
her lashing out this aggressively at
someone just harmlessly laughing at an
awkward moment shows a profound guilt i
like this kid's brand new this i like
your [ __ ] dude xlb pretty good that's
good which i refer you to a poem
published on february 14th i can't do
more poems i can't do more posts no no
we have to the poems are good
just i love it so cruelly so unjustly
as well as their previous boyfriend into
a one-sided open relationship
okay this stuff i'm not going to do that
what i'm saying is yes i do maybe i'm
projecting my me when i'm asked
so all of this is speculation
that being said we can look to people
who know bobby in real life here we go
and see what they think of this
relationship
on march 26th of this year a private
message from bobby's brother was leaked
claiming verbatim
and brainwashed his brother i remember
that systematically and then he said i'm
not gonna talk to him anymore and then
you two ended up breaking up so now you
don't have a brother or a girlfriend
i could tell you what i was making on
the road
i had no other prospects of cash the
only amount of money i was making is
through doing
a b room sometimes
and getting not a door deal but getting
like you know
um
again look at her face look at her you
know
when if you go to his imdb bobby
maintained a consistent average of 5.6
rolls
thank you sir he's playing this i'm poor
thing bro you know how many actors would
die to have that imdb and that's work
that's working he's working
you know and look i'm not saying that
these roles when he's that he's coming
on he's pr he's not he's probably not
making millions of dollars but he's
getting paid well he's getting paid more
than a normal person yeah goals per year
in the five years following mad tv's
conclusion in 2009 and bobby would
continue to maintain an average of 5.6
rolls per year in the five years
following tiger belly's creation and the
quality of these roles haven't
necessarily gone up either
the only stat that has actually seen an
increase is a mere five more episodes of
television appearances a year so this
claim is dubious at best but bobby would
go even further and claim that
everything positive that he had ever
experienced in his entire career was a
direct result of kalila yes pretty much
confirming his brother's brainwashing
accusations
right here right here he's gonna play
he's gonna play it all the things that i
have here
in my life right is a direct result of
meeting her and her her and i building
a business together
um
other things have
grown out of that like you know my it
rekindled my acting career
um you know and also cured his aides
and uh he grew three inches it's true
and his penis is bigger now
bro why are you like this bobby we're
coming to the end here i think we're
done with this clip up
there's some more fun stuff here so do
we only got through half of the video
we'll play more of the video tomorrow
what's this guy's link again um i'm
gonna post the link again uh this guy is
a youtube name is xl
oh i got it um i'm gonna go troll this
guy down be nice to this guy he's uh
anyone that gives his content is fine
fine by me
uh
but yeah man this this is this is like
human accusation because you know
there's there's a lot of brendan like
omnibuses and you can put there's not a
lot this is the first kalila one that
i've actually seen that was like oh [ __ ]
there's [ __ ] in here that i don't even
know then i don't even know i left them
a one-word comment
quality yes
hold on i have to like it
quality
like